[Music
] geopolitics teaches us that keller
european sub-unity has definitely
come to the time for europe to take
its destiny into its own hands
we must demonstrate that east
west south and north we can sow the
seeds of a  more sovereign europe
[Music]
olsen great music aficionados title
facing frankfurt 10 europe and the
big peacock wheel to die for europe and
i don't jump low-esteem financial
ian white house in france' filtering
a cane hush hush i don't know
of amnesty of street fighter iv not too much
that the zoom this sunday hamburg would
not be too much that the human rights watch out
the brown filmed a vase leggings a
soup a solidarity solidarity where
lasagna is formed a simulation
organized parties
we will have to strengthen our capacity  to
speak with one voice on
foreign policy
today the committee is once again proposing to you
to move to
qualified majority voting in the specific areas of
our  external relations would like to
talk to you about the future and therefore about our
continent cousin africa
we need to invest more in our
relations with this great and noble
continent and these individual nations
the commission is today proposing a
new alliance between africa and
europe
an alliance for investments and
produce sustainable employment
we must do more to allow
another single mandate to fully play
its role on the international scene
the euro must become the active instrument
of the new european sovereignty european
imad fattal have come  applause of a
game won't he mali billion of count
european charlie human insights rouge
such the title has talent a cave
after shaft
[Music]
we are all
responsible for europe as it
is and  we will all be responsible for
each
other europe which will be able to stand on its
two legs nation and european union
must  walking together
whoever loves europe must love the
nations that make
it up whoever loves his homeland must love and
can love europe
[Music]